die dadurch sorgen haben wir jetzt den
ersten absatz
das war jetzt kapitel 3 struktur ist
wichtig im zehnten und letzten buch des
dialogs der start verwickelt sokrates
sein gesprächspartner glaukom in eine
diskussion über das böse welches er
durch den mythos dass er einem wieder
vom tode auferstandenen kriegers
illustriert erst seele habe im jenseits
gesehen wie den gerechten nach dem tode
lohn den ungerechten aber strafe für
ihre irdischen taten zu teil geworden
sei der mythos liegt nahe dass die
seelen selbst für ihr lebensschicksal
verantwortlich sind
jetzt habt ihr mal einen kleinen
einblick bekommen wie das hier bei uns
abläuft wenn ihr bock habt uns zu
unterstützen würden wir uns echt freuen
ich mache jetzt mal weiter macht's gut